good morning believe nation today's
message is fill a void over to you Dom
Kennedy fill a void you know fill the
void jobs out here figure out what what
you can make better that's better than
any job like you could go get a job
doing something whatever you don't want
to but figure out where you could really
fit in and be happy and they're worried
about the money's gonna come that's not
gonna be a problem because if you're
filling a void and you add into you know
whatever you might you might be like you
know what they don't have good food I've
been used I'm saying and you might just
be the person in the next billionaire to
just have bomb food at concerts like
straight up though straight up though or
just figure out a way to involve like
media in concerts like where people
could be there and you could live you
know whatever some type of web but just
figure out something that people is not
doing you know I'm saying that you feel
like people could utilize and do that so
a lot of them both successful businesses
that were ever founded with by people
who are scratching our own inch you see
a problem you see something out there
that you don't like you want to solve it
and so you go and do it this is what
makes entrepreneurs successful you know
what separates us from everybody else
most people see a problem and what do
they do they complain right
most people just complain they complain
about the government and they complain
about the transportation system and they
complain about all the negative things
that are happening in their life and
they abdicate responsibility by
complaining we're entrepreneurs we're
the ones who do something about it we're
the ones who see that negative and we
turn it into an opportunity for
ourselves and so if you see yourself
complaining you see yourself wishing
that something else had been created to
solve this problem go out and solve the
problem and then you can sell the
solution to other people so when I look
at my first software company was a
biotech software company was started by
two researchers who were at a university
and they wanted software that could help
them do their experiments more simply
to reduce the number of steps to improve
the efficiency and to create a more
visual product that people could
understand and nothing existed
everything was super scientific and
super technical and they didn't
understand how to use it so they built a
better version for themselves and then
they shared it and that was the genesis
of the first product if I look at this
YouTube channel a lot of the videos that
we end up doing I request it's like what
do you guys want to hear and my request
is well to create this I wanted to be
surrounded by successful people on a
daily basis that's the thesis of this
channel I wanted to be surrounded by
success and use that to push me into a
more powerful direction forward nobody
has done it the way that I wanted it
done nobody was profiling the famous
entrepreneurs in the way that I needed
and so I was consuming all of these
videos and content and hours and hours
and hours of footage to get little hits
you know consume eight hours of Elon
Musk interviews to get like five minutes
of gold
I wanted that process to be simple I
wanted to just turn on YouTube when
there's a video I click play I get
inspired I learned something and I
wanted to be consistent they want to
watch the same video 100 times because
the impact would wear out so this
channel was designed for me and I'm
happy to share it with you guys and we
have this relationship where it's for
both of us and that's amazing and so if
you see a void in the market if you see
a problem that exists that's quite often
your next best business idea that's
where so many of the best businesses
have been built and where your next big
opportunity may be coming from so the
question today is what is the void that
you see and are trying to fix right now
in the market leave it down the comments
below super curious to find out I also
want to give a quick shout out to Gary
Freeman Gary thank you so much for
picking up a couple of my book your
one-word really really means a lot to me
Gary and appreciate the support and I
hope you joined the read so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love and I'll see you guys again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso
very more spray so give me
Stedman and I were in a hotel watching
some bad television and I was
complaining about the state of
television talk shows in particular and
he said why don't you change it why
don't you just get your own Network and
I thought that that was a ridiculous
idea and then he started to talk about
it and he wrote some things down and I
saw the word own at that Oh Oh w oh
that's my those are my initials and I
said wouldn't it be something if I could
create a network that was really about
mindful and I underlined the word
mindful television fifteen years later
those scribblings came closer to reality
when she was approached by David's as
one of the president of the Discovery
Network my view was if we want to do
this you have to be all that she paused
and then she said to me it's meant to be
and we shook hands and that's how I
journeyed again at first I felt great
network oh gee this is the dream I had
and I actually showed him the piece of
paper where I had written it down in
segments and as that started to settle
in with me I thought whoa what is this
I've gotten myself into this is a lot
more work than I ever imagined are you
scared very scared I was very scared and
I would wake up in the middle of the
night literally like clutching my chest
like what have I done what have I done
what if you fail hmm that's what I was
afraid of that's what I was afraid of
the reason why I made the decision to go
forward is because I believe that people
deserve to have value centered
inspirational programming for themselves
I believe that television has become in
many ways banal it has become insipid
and not not all of it but I think that I
have something to offer what
circumstances were present that made
this idea catch fire sure so I think
there was sort of two components in the
first component
it's probably that social media is
starting to feel a little stale so
there's only so many beautiful
attractive cool pictures that you can
take and when you see all of them day
after day after day it just kind of gets
boring so I think there was that aspect
of it and then I think the other thing
is that we really identified that this
ephemeral thing was core to conversation
and so if you want to have a
conversation one of the best parts about
it was that you were left with the
memory but not necessarily a transcript
and I think that that really drove the
great feeling that you have when you you
know share snaps with friends and
they're silly and you know not exactly
perfect you know there was obviously a
place for all of these great photos that
you wanted to save and keep and there
wasn't so much a place to have a
conversation and I think you know
there's a nice balance with both and so
I think we sort of filled maybe avoid
the conversation but that was missing
I just think music is changing in terms
of the gatekeepers and the power that
the the positi and I feel like it's in a
more democratic time it's like the power
is in the musicians hands and in the
fans and I mean they choose you know
what what matters what's relevant what
sells what you know it's not so much
like the old powers the old gatekeepers
who could just shove something down your
throat it's like you know you you see
less and less superstars and more and
more organically grown you know artists
like myself who are just you know just
doing something a little different you
know they mean bending genres and don't
necessarily fit within this like format
or walls of you know whatever it's kind
of doing their own thing and finding an
audience and and growing it organically
and making it happen